é muito boa tarde doutor tem uma
responsabilidade para aqui um orgulhoso
e tem um bocado nervosa não é nada eu
falar um bocadinho de mim eu tive um
acidente no ano 2000 resultante de uma
casa e e as acidente durante meio ano
estive deitada numa cama também
conseguimos ser
e eu acho que foi a minha maior
experiência nível espiritual de me
conhecer a mim própria e de saber que
até os 25 anos foi o mais jovem com
baixa autoestima uma pessoa muito muito
frase a nível emocional que era incapaz
de estar aqui os a falar e foi um
período muito difícil da minha vida em
que eu vi durante meio ano a mesma
paisagem no mesmo vidro o quarto branco
os medicamentos para uma pessoa que era
ativa foi um choque brutal mas a maior
diferente da amadurecimento a maior
experiência a nível emocional e de
fortalecimento e depois fui para o
hospital de reabilitação onde esteve
internada há mais de 3 anos
e aí para dizer o que é que esse três
anos de internamento eram para que eu
pudesse comprar a nível físico mais
positivo e que pudesse no fundo ser uma
pessoa minimamente autônoma na minha
vida diária mas aquilo para mim foi um
momento difícil e o momento em que eu
percebi que a tela e eu era uma pessoa
infeliz com o metade da minha alma vazia
porque eu não encontrei um caminho até
os meus 25 anos onde supostamente anda
para eu tinha tudo para ser feliz eu não
acho
é mas quando percebi nesse três anos que
eu tive internada e que olhei para para
o lado tem olhar para o meu umbigo vi
centenas de jovens e pessoas mais
adultas na mesma condição que eu e
algumas delas muito pior esse assunto
like muito grande na minha cabeça de
perceber que nós vamos às vezes estamos
agonistas que se olharmos para o nosso
umbigo e a partir daí eu posso dizer que
eu encontrei meu caminho e encontrei o
meu caminho e hoje sou uma mulher muito
mais feliz muito mais realizada uma
pessoa muito mais ativa e que faço
há tantas coisas que eu não consegui
fazer a pé porque não tinha coragem para
fazer e dizer o sol singu esta cadeira
rosa está aqui foi a maior lição da
minha vida é o meu maior orgulho e é que
o que eu sinto que é o meu designo meu
caminho hoje estar aqui e poder olhar
para você já passou nervoso e passar os
uma mensagem de dizer que eu deito na
vida para conhecer construir uma vida
construir uma história e fazer tudo
diferente que eu não fiz até ali porque
hoje eu sinto que sou eu estou aqui que
sou capaz que estou feliz que sou uma
mulher bonita sou uma pessoa
independente que cheguei aqui a conduzir
conseguir ter a minha autonomia e tudo
na vida passa por nós sermos capazes de
tudo e a maior barreira que
o ser humano após o meu acidente que a
tela e não tinha noção disso a barreira
humana pior que existe que a mentalidade
ou seja quando eu sou sabemos que não
somos capazes quando olhamos para o lado
e achamos que aquela pessoa que tem
algum problema que tem uma alimentação
ou quando no fundo achamos que a
sociedade tem que ser divisível por
conceitos preconceitos e e por tudo
aquilo que limita a queremos fazer
aquilo que me faz coisas e hoje posso
dizer que sou uma pessoa extremamente
emotiva que me libertei até aos 25 anos
daquilo que era racional que toda a
gente me dizia que a minha vida tinha
que ser assim hoje não eu faço aquilo
que eu quero aquilo que eu estou feliz e
aquilo que eu sei que eu tenho grande
coragem para o fazer que é desenvolver
um projeto uma história de vida estar
aqui hoje inspirar outras pessoas a
dizer tudo é possível tudo é que é
é capaz de ser tornando realidade quando
nós pensamos com o coração e quando nós
pensamos com coração nós fazemos aquilo
que estamos felizes fazemos as pessoas à
nossa volta muito mais feliz e esta
minha história de vida é acho que é das
coisas mais importantes que eu já fiz
até hoje e que me deixa tão feliz de
estar em vários vídeos a falar com o
várias pessoas a partilhar um bocadinho
daquilo que a minha experiência de vida
e no fundo ver que as pessoas o primeiro
impacto que causa uma cadeira de rodas
inter ela é muito quase e provavelmente
não faz nada na vida e está em casa a
chorar a serem ruins não eu estou uma
melhor realizada e feliz e posso dizer
que 19 anos após acidente já gastei
muitas cadeiras que essa não é primeiro
já não tinha pneus sou uma pessoa
extremamente ativa e eu sou eu sou o que
sou dinâmica que gosto de ser
empreendedora
eu queria empresário que era uma
história de vida online que vocês podem
consultar que o projeto estará contigo
no facebook e
e eu acho que mais do que estar aqui a
falar e contar os mais sobre mim e eu
preparei um vídeo que é um vídeo
motivacional que tem uma mensagem para
todos vós espero que alguma coisa muito
importante e visível vocês lá vendo aqui
hoje para no fundo termos um mundo
melhor e podemos ver as coisas de uma
forma diferente
e aí
[Música]
g1
e aí
[Música]
g1
e aí
[Música]
o ser humano que eu sei o que fazer
quando acredita quando dá tudo e o meu
sonho foi mesmo após acidente que querer
ser uma pessoa diferente querer fazer
algo de muito importante começar a vida
crescer o meu só ativei autônoma e no
fundo não deixar que a sociedade no
processo de lado porque eu acho que eu e
todos os ser humanos têm direito a ter
uma vida a ser integrado e no fundo como
disse há bocado na apresentação o grande
sonho que eu tenho que realmente
portugal seja cada vez mais inclusive
casa mais tarde casa mais pessoas como
eu a terem esta autonomia a terem essa
alegria de viver a poderem fazer algo de
útil porque quando as pessoas são
estimuladas e tem esse este impulso de
dizer realmente nós vamos ajudar outras
pessoas a serem felizes e deixar de
olhar para o nosso um vídeo e começar a
olhar para aquilo que nos
a circunda eu acho que somos todos muito
mais ricos quando acreditamos no ser
humano e aquilo que eu fiz também a
história de vida justamente isso foi o
número queria esconder porque eu acho
que é uma coisa pode acontecer a
qualquer um queria ter uma vida autônoma
e querer ser uma pessoa integrante na
sociedade porque eu nunca vou permitir
que a sociedade me fizeste o contrário
embora é sempre isso que que num caso
como o meu acontece porque as pessoas
acham sempre que a pessoa não vai ter
capacidade de fora e a palavra ou a
frase que me impulsiona o sempre para
nunca estar quieta porque eu não consigo
estar quieta foi dizer-me constantemente
não pode se tu não vais conseguir
e essa foi a grande sabe passaram
continuar estar aqui por eu ser uma
pessoa com a capacidade que tenho hoje e
entrei aqui no estado do pânico do medo
e agora está aqui eu estou feliz porque
estou a passar uma mensagem que acho que
a impactante que vai mudar um bocadinho
as vossas cabeças e no fundo este é o
meu trabalho que eu faço hoje quer mudar
mentalidade e de dizer as pessoas quando
nós acreditamos o mesmo muito que nós
somos capazes em alguma coisa nós somos
mesmo capaz as ferramentas estão dentro
de nós e muitas vezes nós vamos procurar
nos outros aquilo que nos faz falta e o
meu grande percurso neste momento é um
percurso de autoconhecimento de testar
constantemente os meus limites de dizer
eu agora vou ser feliz eu quero ser
feliz eu vou fazer tudo aquilo que me
apaixona e se me disserem constantemente
não tô no conselhos como vais fazer é
a palavra que me dá logo adrenalina
fazer não são os pés aqui eu vou te
mostrar que realmente tudo é capaz que
eu posso fazer aquilo que eu quiser eu
posso ser aquilo que eu quiser em
qualquer parte do mundo desde que nós
cidade que veremos a barreira seu para
mim acho que que é pior do que é da
mentalidade de assarmos que a perfeição
existe no a perfeição e eu adoro ser
imperfeita adoro ser uma mulher como
mobilidade produzido adoro estar aqui a
falar e adoro dizer-vos isto porque ele
sentei-me realmente que eu sou eu não
tenho qualquer problema e aqui em
guimarães para mim é um orgulho estar
aqui na minha cidade a contar a minha
história porque todas as pessoas que me
vem na rua ir às compras sozinha a
conduzir a ter o meu dia a dia a
trabalhar ir para o ginásio ataques dos
meus amigos a sair à noite e as pessoas
e acabam por criar um respeito e acabam
por criar uma admiração porque existe
muito poucas pessoas que mataram que eu
tinha em guimarães a ter uma vida
autônoma porque elas estão escondidas
mas existe e eu pergunto porque é que
elas não são incluídas na sociedade e
não podem estar no ambiente em ter todos
todos nós e eu acho que nós temos no
fundo de um cadinho o dever de tornar
guimarães inclusive tornar guimarães uma
cidade para todos e que todos nós
possamos desfrutar de tudo aquilo que a
cidade tem que o país tem e comum tem
porque eu acho que o país o mundo é de
todos e não é só para alguns por isso é
que eu dei tudo na vida por isso é que
ele tem orgulho na mulher em que me
tornei por isso é que o meu pé
com efeito a diferença e o projeto sara
coutinho estar aqui hoje é uma grande
vitória porque foi um projeto particular
que eu fundei com a minha história de
vida mas que está a fazer a diferença e
hoje está no tabaco e para mim é um
orgulho mente e agradeço a todos faltam
18 minutos e 17 segundos se alguém
quiser fazer alguma pergunta
e aí
é obrigado a